meurtre au premier degré comment plaidez-vous l'
enlèvement avec l'intention de
commettre un viol admettez-vous ou niez-vous le meurtre
au premier degré qui accuse monsieur comment
plaidez-vous
[Musique]
[Musique  ]
il entrait dans la maison et attachait le
mari, puis retirait essentiellement la
femme de la chambre et commettait son
agression sexuelle souvent en mangeant dans
la maison là-bas, donc il était là pendant de nombreuses
heures parfois, il retirait également des
objets de l'intérieur des maisons
[  Musique]
[Musique]
les réponses là-bas, nous avons besoin d'un nom
parce que lorsque nous associerons ce nom à ce
profil, ce voyage pour la justice
prendra fin et donc je supplie
tout le monde ici à Sacramento de savoir si
vous pensiez connaître un nom  vous avez entendu
quelque chose quoi que ce soit
[Musique]
l'échantillon était un échantillon de vous savez que
le tueur d'erreurs de l'école de la région de l'Est a été
utilisé dans les sites de généalogie et à partir de là, une
lignée familiale a été développée et à partir de
là, beaucoup de travail a été fait  par
detec  tives et comme je dis la construction des
arbres pour trouver la relation qu'il
peut vous connaître finalement nous nous a conduits à mr.
D'Angelo et à partir de ce moment-là, une fois que nous avons en
quelque sorte été amenés à lui,
les échantillons ont été collectés
subrepticement, ce qui correspondait alors,
nous connaissons maintenant l'extérieur d'un
Pascal et restons tueur
[Musique]
vous